it was the Independence Day that never
was and under clear blue skies and
bright sunshine the anger of those who
hoped to leave but have yet to see it
spilled out onto the streets of
Westminster what they're doing in there
is not democracy they stand up there in
a bet little boxes and telling us what
is good for us they've got no idea
what's good for us
No Deal no problem No Deal no problem
you hope this was meant to be breakfast
day the big day the day that people took
back control instead it is a march on
Parliament paralyzed by indecision and
infighting but take away the flags and
the banners it is another day in their
Tereza May's withdrawn agreement
rejected again what do you think about
what I think that's disgraceful that
we've not left jack I think it's
unlawful and I think we should leave
in all fairness visit it's not fair that
we haven't left we don't want anything
to do with them when we voted that so
let's get out before I start getting
annoyed you get really start squaring
29th of March should have been the day
you leave and in my eyes we've left but
it's not and you haven't so what in my
eyes we have today is our Independence
Day and whether we have it or not we're
celebrating it and we're going to
celebrate it next year and the year
after
what do you want what do you want to see
happen in that building the House of
Commons now in the vacuum caused by a
stalled brexit in stepped the far right
a blocked bricks it could lead to a
surge in support for prominent activists
like Tommy Robinson over in Parliament
Square Nigel Farage the former you kept
leader who helped to spearhead brexit
urge the crowd to fight on
it has been another bruising day for the
prime minister faith in her in the
government in the political system here
at least in a grave State McMartin Sky
News Westminster